beautiful
so beautiful
[Music]
it's easy to cook on tv there's talented
producers there's [ __ ] editors and
there's all sorts of things that make
you look good you know before any tv
came anywhere near my career
i'd mastered my craft you'll see a side
to me
across this class that i don't think has
ever been shown before
nice skills the basics are so important
three fingers down
and this beautiful knuckle is the
guiding light across that knife
cooking salmon so the secret is to score
the skin that stops the fish from
buckling up
you can't pick up the world's best
cookbook and understand it you need to
do it
delicious everything i've learned
understood stolen
perfected is laid bare across this
master class
for the first time ever you could learn
how to cook those ingredients
from start to finish i've just spent the
last 30 years
busting my ass off to get on the plate
what i'm about to show you
and watch but watch carefully
i'm gordon ramsay and this is my master
[Music]
class
you